it is easy to sit back and let others
control and influence our lives to give
up and accept life's conditions as they
are handed to us without questioning or
selecting them but as humans we have the
profound ability to choose the ability
to examine consider and select or
deselect how we wish to live and see
things if you sit submissive and choose
to not choose in life you give others
the ability to choose for you you lose
control of your unique psychological
world there are as many psychological
worlds as there are people within this
one physical world a psychological world
is the objective world as a particular
consciousness perceives and experiences
it it is the sum of a person's genetic
dispositions conditioned behaviors and
experiences developing into one unique
vantage point as a result 7 billion
people experience a slightly different
color of the same world and every person
experiences a slightly different color
of you people see you in the ways that
fit their own world and you do the same
for them this is ok though because one
can maintain their own world while also
existing in others what we must be
careful of though is losing control of
our own world in the process it is OK to
inspire or be inspired by those we
encounter in life but it is damaging to
completely accept all the versions of
the world that other people see when we
do this we accept everyone's color as
our own and become a mix of too many
colors
all blending into a murky neutral Brown
instead we must be selective and
conscious of the colors we let our own
mix with we must maintain a unique and
beautiful color that is distinctive and
self righteous best way to accomplish
this is by realizing that your version
of the world is not all there is if your
color is unique then so must everyone
else's when we realize this we no longer
feel the need for our color to match
with everyone else's we cease trying to
absorb other people's and other people's
will no longer be able to passively
absorb ours
only when we admit that the world exists
in seven billion different forms can we
begin to focus on controlling our own
you
you